but you know maybe you don't have the
money to splurge on tickets to go see
the raiders in person well you don't
have to
wait for the season to start to also
represent the silver and black
alex the place just for you to become
part of raiders nation is open
yeah the first official raiders theme
restaurant opens today
inside the m resort hector mejia already
there live with a bunch of kegs
hi hector ready to go hey there
yeah this is the keg room where the
weather forecast here is a chilly 39
degrees so
we're highlighting this room because
they have about 20 beers on tap here at
this brand new restaurant
and really everywhere you look you see
silver and black as well as some
memorabilia
i want to introduce the vpn general
manager here at the m resort we have
hussein to talk to us all right how
unique is this and is there something
like this
anywhere else in the world that we know
of there is no official raiders themed
restaurant anywhere in the entire world
and i believe we're one of the only
official sports bar tavern restaurants
affiliated with the team where the team
is actively involved in the design and
construction
just you know just to get an idea what
was here before uh
here was our restaurant jade fusion it's
our asian kind of fusion restaurant and
it was fantastic and we have every
intention of bringing asian food back
another place in this casino
but 200 seats is just way too big for an
asian restaurant
200 seats that's uh that's a pretty
large number for people yeah
it is and you know most successful asian
restaurants are somewhere in the
25 to 75 seat range and we really
thought
this is a great space and it would be a
perfect tavern and grill because of the
amount of volume we can do here
and this is a locals resort this is
really going to bring people together
also those coming from out of town to
cheer on the raiders
yeah you know obviously a huge amount of
raiders fans are from l.a
and we get a ton of our business from la
san bernardino riverside
because they've been to the strip 100
times and they're still looking for a
billion dollar resort experience but
they don't want to put up with the
hassle of parking fees and
bachelorette parties and everything else
going on so they come here
a nice escape from the bachelorette
party there you go so you know what i'm
talking about
thank you very much so besides the
concept they also have some stadium
favorites right
we do so we're going to have all of your
normal stuff like build your own
hamburger or barbecue ribs but also
we're gonna have crab legs wagyu skirt
steak and a lot of the great stuff for
dinner
awesome sounds delightful so i'll stick
around and you know it actually smells
like bacon right now as they get ready
to
start their day and that's your live
look inside reporting live hector mejia
what do you guys think hector's like i
know exactly what you're talking about
yeah it smells like making bacon in my
life well
yes and the end resort's only you know
not that far away from the raiders
training facility as well so it all
seems to make sense it'd be right next
door so good stuff hector thank you very
much
enjoy the bacon save the beer